oh god I was in tact the menu seems to
be missing welcome welcome to city 17
welcome to potato mode the show where we
take your favorite games and make them
look like mush I'm joined once again by
Ben djenka hello learner and we are in a
very special episode of potato mode
because we are playing half-life Alex in
VR I'm so nervous
Avery you brave soul I don't know how
you're gonna be able to stomach seeing
these things right in your oh boy it's
gonna be a mess because let me tell you
dude this game looks gorgeous it's one
of the most impressive VR games I've
ever played and I'm ready to just throw
up when you start messing with it
I can barely wait you've been working on
your VR flips oh yeah oh god oh Jesus
that's real bad Oh I'm here to see if
any of the potato stuff messes with the
marker capability so this this is all
all cranked up high settings like we're
yeah this is high settings where we're
running this this game looks gorgeous Oh
what you gonna draw uh-huh
what's but saying on what you've got
very good VR handwriting thank you
it's tricky it is so you're doing a
thing that you isn't really there but
it's there that's amazing hello there we
go
there it is yeah curling like that you
know yeah I hear you
there's such nice drawings may I get his
mess with this stuff forever this hat I
wear that hanging like for safety but
these are also for safety up for safety
that guy he's safe
what tell safe he is he's she's
definitely safe got put these boots on
to probably for you know I I really wish
you could I know I'm like trying to do
it
I can I can I can like magically see
your foot like going in these boys are
nasty you know but how much do you think
Timmy and Tommy would pay for one of
them oh that's a good question how much
money can I get at the nuke shop exactly
this games really gross in a great way I
love it love it
awesome okay so yeah Your Honor I think
we've shown how cool the game looks it's
incredibly impressive
obviously you can't get the true sense
of it without being in VR yourself but
now is the very nervous moment where
we're gonna completely ruin this okay
Ben here we are in the Nvidia profile
inspector yeah we are just gonna change
a couple of settings just like see what
happens
oh I get there's a difference it's a
little smoother some ground missing over
there
wonderful wonderful so already we're
doing great
oh god that was intact the menu seems to
be missing Ben can you yes a video or
something shot of the menu for me so if
the top is continued and underneath it
aims and then start a new game is the
third option okay I think I hit a new
game so I want chapter 1 that should be
this one chapter 1 the very top oh okay
there you go okay what do i do again
that should be sort of the bottom left
for the except okay there's normally
text here for start it's not this time
there's no text no story no nothing
we've removed it off opening shots in a
beer oh I'm so nervous
Oh Oh the textures are all gone okay uh
my hands actually looks kind of okay
okay I'm kind of I'm kind of actually
into this yeah not bad oh wait hold on
this is the most important thing because
okay I was gonna say I don't see any of
the marker on there that's there before
no you can't write at all it's a real
bummer all right ten wins this potato
mode is not good anymore
ah if it isn't my father
the signal is it's cutting I can't
yeah oh hello what happened to you are
you okay are you all right get did you
get help will you get you help
oh god don't think everything this is
the opposite of what's happening
I'll say the good news is it doesn't
make me feel like sick at all thanks
good hey I'm glad about that that's
that's a good thing it's more that I get
to see like the effects of potato mode
but like in in real life now I've taken
up putting the game in the potato fire
we put you in the potato
I've been potato fide whoa there's no
trees no that's it's a real real
see-through situation
the boys just yeah just kind of like
like Solid Snake his gun Oh first thing
I did when that thing got in my face was
I liked it
instinctually just pushed it away Oh No
thank you
the gun model still looks I mean they
just look I can't tell many bullets I
have so that's kind of unfortunate in
the shotgun here the pistol I can still
I can still see the pistol bullets so
that works oh it's one of the gross ones
you know it was gonna like lose itself
on the that corner like that cuz that
was really pro totally 100% yes awesome
I love it hun percent calculated hello
hello hey hello yes potato mode
the phones for you about this guy what's
he look like
he's he looks like a like a ghost like a
we're all ghosts there you go that's
buddy while I'm killing it you want a
hit
oh wait you can't see your ammo counter
but I can you can oh right because you
got the inventory hold on yeah so you
got four shots that's good to know
load how many shots do I have two one
drag him over get him into the light
dragon sky Kenny you know it's good good
grip and move them around yeah there you
go
there we go hello oh no oh yeah that
looks rough I mean it looks kind of less
terrifying than the original me I can't
I don't know what do you think I like
how his jaw has is like separate physics
uh how's this puzzle gonna look very
curious okay
actually it was the exact same yeah
that's good actually very nice I
appreciate that
okay banked it Oh tufa watch you one
hell yeah Oh got him
did you like practiced with these
grenades beforehand you're like I played
this part before yesterday it was very
bad when I first played it so you're
just like double me crying oh yeah I
know where all these guys arm just
please I'm grenade Pro over here oh no
Jesus
let's loose both in regular and potato
that is very very uncomfortable yeah
right
oh [ __ ] no no wow Oh No Hank yeah - just
just double fist just take two in and
toss them both all the same time yeah Oh
God bonus oh my god what is it going on
with me Jesus Christ a little too much
info Oh what the double toss kidding me
whoever's editing this cut all of this
out don't show any of this Rabin's what
I ran out of grenades
oh they reload because we know perfect
all right there we go
Jesus I can't believe you did that in
one try
I know tell because the the holder is
still full of grenade yeah I definitely
100% did it in my first try I'm awesome
that's unfortunate
yep that you've got 42 BISM there you go
actually there you go yeah you did it
what'd I get you got the scope okay I
wanted the laser dot which I'm
interesting learn how the scope of look
the exact same actually okay I don't
know what I'm picking is that laser dot
yeah it looks like it might be lasers or
not because it's got the wire wrapping
around the side I don't think that's the
laser dot I don't think it's the lasers
not either now to be honest well
yeah that's the ticket
yeah number one see it's the it's the
double grenade technique it never fails
what's my health that I can't tell Oh
like 75% of one heart sick all you can
see him better cuz there's no goo yeah
that's some really bad when he gets
squished yeah I'm not looking for - that
poor guy sorry
I don't like that it's like his face
right up against the glass let's don't
look yeah there we go that's much better
outdoor environments are just so good I
know even potato fide this game still
looks really impressive
trees are a little you know missing some
definition maybe but hey it's our old
friend what up buddy look I don't like
how that stuff on the Left looks with
the holes in it that's kind of making me
uncomfortable
it looks less gross and with the potato
five oh yeah right there looks no good
though mmm like the textures are not
happy yeah that's again not too bad what
do you want uh that I've got it here you
go
that's for you who wanted to just vodka
I've got you not that one that was a bad
one oh we've got I actually like the
atmosphere in here a lot more happiness
I've told you it's less creepy in potato
mode not nearly as gross looking in
noticing kind of like the more colored
lights - a bit more I think yeah oh that
looks a little old Yankee oh yeah it's
like a candle
you know uh knowing what's down here
makes me realize that's not wax though
sky pick this up nope I mess that up hey
don't throw that bottle at me yeah hurry
are how do you like it if I throw a
bottle at you yeah almost fell over ooh
Oh God hello oh you got rid right inside
of him yeah
this part is genuinely creepy Oh
Oh God reveille they managed to kind of
keep some of this feels creepier for
some reason now it's cuz it's it's hard
to see on top of it already being harder
to see because there isn't any like I
don't know he's he's less info you're
kidding at first it was less creepy and
now it's more creepy
well alright everybody thank you for
watching this episode of potato mode I
hope it gave you a good look at how this
game looks potato fide in VR gotta love
doing the outro and having a headcrab
try to crash the party yeah really great
yeah I would say surprisingly it's
actually playable like it doesn't affect
your ability to play so I can recommend
you could try this and you're not gonna
get any more sick then you already
normally would in VR as long as you have
somebody to tell you where the menu
buttons are so anyway thanks for
watching and I'll see you next time well
nope [ __ ] shut up